aujourd'hui bien ouverts bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être notre invité mais
savez-vous très bien bon on va vous
poser la question surtout comment ça va
au sein de votre parti vous êtes député
des républicains de vaucluse président
doser la france en détention pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale bonjour stéphane bern et
bonjour stéphane qui dirige le bureau
parisien du journal ouest france et on
va évidemment parler de ce qui se passe
au sein de votre parti et julien baer
puisque le meeting de valérie pécresse
interroge au sein même de votre famille
politique et particulièrement l'emploi
de cette expression grand remplacement
qu'elle a utilisé en disant qu'il n'y
avait pas de façade de fatalité ni gros
grande et classement ni au grand
remplacement est ce qu employé cette
expression qu'utilisent les rides
zemmour c'est une erreur de sa part ce
qu'on a le droit d'utiliser des mots
dont on conteste le fondement évidemment
les pécresse d'ailleurs ne s'était pas
caché pendant le congrès de cette
divergence de vue d'ailleurs j'en
profite pour dire que quand eric zemmour
utilise le grand emplacement et si de
camus inapte à lucas mieux ce qui aurait
été une mélange ce que camus appelle le
grand remplacement et le petit
remplacement mais si un jour ça
intéresse des gens qui veulent se
pencher sur le fond dans discutera et la
balle a tout simplement expliqué que ne
reprenait pas cette expression si elle
avait dit je ne me résous pas à la
fatalité ni à l'explosion l'union
européenne ni l'esclavagisme on n'aurait
pas dit valérie pécresse et esclavagiste
voyez donc un moment donné la négation
en français le fait d'ailleurs de mettre
un point si on veut être précis
grammaticalement entre deux phrases
manifeste bien une coupure dans la
pensée mais quand même savait très bien
qu'elle est connoté
connoté ces banques elles l'utilisent
c'est pour dire moi je ne suis je ne me
résous pas à ce à la france que d'écrire
examen là la nouvelle france ça n'est
pas la france avec ses bons et prenez
les réactions qui ont pu qui ont pu qui
ont pu enfin qui se sont fait jour à la
suite de ceux de l'usagé steak n'auront
pas du tout je pense qu'on serait drôle
quand non je pense qu'il ya eu une
véritable instrumentalisation de cette
affaire
coordonnées concertée dans différents
médias par les proches du président de
la république et par une partie de la
gauche et d'ailleurs j'ai vu sortir des
sarcophages la vieille gauche avec les
crucifix expliquant que nous avions
perdu la boussole républicaine
monsieur le drian mam hidalgo
se permet de donner des leçons de
république donc il ya eu si vous voulez
cette volonté pour dire grosso modo
c'est le réductions at le péno donc
elles utilisent ces mots là donc ça y
est à la franchise ruby quand elle n'est
plus dans le champ républicain
vous n'avez pas la machine à breveter
les républicains vous n'êtes vous même
d'ailleurs pas souvent républicain la
mairie de paris l'ong laissez nous
tranquille puis deuxièmement vous avez
bien parce que si vous voulez quand vous
sur nous donc quand vous êtes avec des
écologistes et que lorsque vous voulez
donner le nom d'une rue samuel pâtit
vous avez un débat avec des gens qui
sont vos propres alliés en disant ah oui
mais quand même ça va un peu trop loin
moi je pense que si vous voulez
s'intéresser surtout l'été est plutôt
sur la durée alors juste on va revenir à
ce qui se passe au sein de votre famille
alors de votre conseil stratégique parce
qu'il n'ya pas que la gauche et les
maquereaux nice le pied en anglais hier
et vous aviez affronté xavier bertrand
et jean-françois copé ont demandé des
clarifications à valérie pécresse veut
conserver non je sais pas exactement
la réunion a duré 40 minutes je nous
avons fait le point chacun en fait à
exprimer effectivement on le sait
diagnostic sur le congrès aller rider on
ne s'en est pas caché sur la forme sur
le fond simplement on était en train de
discuter si vous voulez du fait que bfm
tv n'avait pas eu le retour soit enfin
des détails techniques et xavier
bertrand a dit le problème il n'est pas
sur la technique le problème il y qu'il
faut que t'arrêtes d'écouter tout le
monde que tu essaies de faire la
synthèse de tout le monde qu'il soit toi
même parce que les gens je veux
retrouver là valérie pécresse du congrès
et d'ailleurs je lui dis la même chose
je vous ai dit vers 3 il n'a pas dit à
valérie pécresse le grand emplacement
ces panneaux il est dit non il a dit il
faut je compte tenu de la polémique qui
a surgi il faut être très clair
lorsqu'on parle du grand emplacement
effectivement pour éviter de laisser
entendre voilà parce qu'on voit bien le
piège qui nous est tendu donc sur cette
expression qu'on soit clair entre nous
ce qu'on a voulu dire voilà ce que si
vous voulez moi j'ai un vrai dire qu'il
faut des clarifications non ça veut dire
que lorsque vous avez une polémique
comme celle ci avec des gens qui
essayent de laisser entendre que vous
avez utilisé cette expression pour
valider eric zemmour faut qu'on soit
bien clair entre nous sur nos éléments
de langage sur la position qu'on tient
et que ce soit très bien claires entre
nous qu'il s'agissait pas du tout de
reprendre cette aide alors est-ce que
l'erreur c'est plutôt que de reprendre
cette expression l'utiliser valérie
précresse n'aurait-elle pas mieux fait
de sa de s'en prendre directement à eric
zemmour ce qu'elle n'a pas fait au cours
du salon si moi je pense que c'était
plus clair n'en est plus simple je pense
qu'elle n'a pas voulu elle n'a pas
prononcé le nom de ses concurrents
emmanuel macron à quelques reprises mais
je crois que l'objet de ce discours
c'était davantage de présenter sa vision
de la nouvelle france sont sa vision
la voulions pas si vous voulez rentrer
dans un règlement de comptes tels que
eric zemmour a pu le faire de manière
assez assez dur d'ailleurs au lance
flammes dans son discours on n'était pas
sur le même niveau c'est ça mais juste
sur ce qui s'est passé hier parce que là
vous me lisez un peu par exemple jean
françois copé lui aussi
qu'il n'a pas
les choses et de dire qu'il fallait une
ligne avec les extrêmes alors jean
françois copé de la manière dont il a
dit autant qu'ils avaient bien trop
effectivement je me souviens
effectivement de ces propos que je n'ai
pas interprété comme la presse a pu
faire autant jean françois copé s'est
passé inaperçu e détenant pas parler si
il a parlé des jeux n'est pas retenue
j'ai surtout retenu qu'il ay la pila il
a rappelé le fait que c'était lui soit
la loi sur la burqa que ces voix là que
c'était lui qui avait été si
l'intervention xavier bien voilà sur la
droite décomplexée va je n'ai pas le
souvenir si vous voulez moi de ce
passage mais vous comprenez quand même
que d'une manière générale quand on
regarde les choses un peu de l'extérieur
on a le sentiment où on a l'impression
que valérie pécresse est dans la roue de
d'eric zemmour de marine le pen qu'elle
cherche soit gardé ses électeurs qui
seraient tentés par la droite de la
droite soit faire revenir des gens de
son côté dans la famille est ce que ça
c'est une bonne stratégie et je vais je
vais préciser ma question si imaginons
que valérie pécresse soit au deuxième
tour comment elle fait ensuite pour
rassembler bout et élargir sa base
rassembler un centre après avoir eu des
propos ou une attitude qui la marque
très à droite de la droite alors d'abord
jeux jeux il ya plusieurs choses en
vendant ce que vous dites vous avez
besoin d'abord d'expliquer votre vision
par rapport à celles des autres dont
vous prenez leurs mots si c'est pour les
combattre ce n'est pas si vous voulez
une reprise des thèses l'a jamais dit
moi je suis favorable au grand
remplacement ou je pense que le
remplacement existent il ya quand même
une certaine de thématique ou deuxième
de proximité vous êtes d'accord enfin et
là si vous voulez entre la droite et
l'extrême droite vous avez parfois des
thèmes qui sont repris ensemble on parle
tous les deux ensemble de la nation mais
vous avez d'un côté et je parle pas de
candidat je parle de l'extrême droite
qui peut être en partie si vous voulez
d'un certain mais vous avez une vision
en gros de la nation blanche et
l'identité d'une civilisation où
l'immigré est rejetée parce qu'il n'est
pas de la bonne couleur de peau c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que je n'aime pas
beaucoup la notion de grand remplacement
qui appelle en fait à la visibilité on
dit aux gens regardez autour de vous
mais la couleur de peau ne veut rien
dire de votre intégration républicaine
le vrai sujet il est culturel bon et
puis de l'autre côté une droite qui
parle de la nation et des frontières
parce qu'elle dit notre modèle
l'assimilation républicaine est plus
capable d'assimiler donc il faut arrêter
l'immigration donc on peut avoir le même
thème pour l'interpréter différemment
deuxièmement il y as si vous voulez dans
la vente et valérie pécresse d'occuper
toute la droite d'aller puis d'ailleurs
il y avait des gens christophe lagarde
hervé morin jusqu'à laurent wauquiez
eric ciotti tout le monde était là et
moi j'ai entendu ce discours tout le
monde on y reviendra beaucoup de choses
la souveraineté l'identité la loi sur
les propriétés avec ses terres par
équipes sont proches de leur donner des
idées que je défends c'est la france
donc vous êtes effectivement elle occupe
tout le champ de la droite maintenant le
second tour je vais vous dire le centre
d'abord il est déjà avec
avec nous avec deux deux composantes
dont on a beaucoup parlé d'ailleurs et
vous avez aujourd'hui beaucoup de gens
de gauche qui se poseront la question
que je crois si vous voulez que le sujet
sera plus tôt emmanuel macron ce encore
ou cinq ans ou pas et vous avez des gens
de gauche qui devront faire un choix et
valérie pécresse on sait d'où elle vient
elle n'est pas si vous voulez le vient
pas de l'ailé droite des républicains à
la base et je les perds une droite
chiraquienne mais elle est d'une droite
chiraquienne et elle ne dit pas
attention moi je partage l'idée d'une
france sépia ou non au contraire elle
dit ça n'est pas la france ça n'est pas
le projet que je veux pour se payer
justement vous le dit eh bien elle vient
pas de la droite elle est plutôt
centriste
je reviens pas de la droite vient pas de
la droite dure
dure et des barres de chocolat pur sang
tu es que du coup son discours qui est
quand même très à droite plus abstrait
droit gonzalez que du coup ça ne serait
pas dans l'enfance c'est comme ça va
tourner parce que vous avez sur sûr
quand on parle de france à pied gauche
c'est quand même c'est quand même pas
des mots qu'on al'habitude longtemps
dans la tête mais qu'est-ce que derrière
les mots qu'est ce que ça veut dire
savez vous avez des gens aujourd'hui qui
ont des papiers d'identité français mais
qui ne se comporte de manière française
il ne s'assimile pas ils ne respectent
pas les lois de la république et je veux
dire le vrai sujet c'est pas les mots
vous utilisez les suit les suit les mots
ne sont que les véhicules des idées la
question que vous vous devriez vous
poser et que les français devraient se
poser c'est est-ce que je suis d'accord
ou pas avec le fait que valérie pécresse
préfère le français de coeur aux
français de papier est ce à dire celui
qui n'a peut-être pas les papiers
français mais qui aime ce pays et celui
qui a peut-être le papier la carte
d'identité mais qui ne respectent pas
les lois et bien moi je crois
qu'effectivement d'ailleurs c'est une
différence avec certains qui sont plus à
droite que nous qu'ils toujours
préférence nationale mais moi entre moi
j'ai j'ai dans ma rue quelqu'un qui est
d'origine macédonienne qui se lève tous
les matins 5 heures du matin pour faire
travailler ses enfants et qui à la sueur
de son front
inquiète sa propriété je le respecte
beaucoup plus que certains qui peuvent
être françois de français depuis
vercingétorix et dont le seul et unique
objectif est surtout de jamais mais si
vous vous dites à la raison il faut
aller chercher ses électeurs qui sont
tentés par eric zemmour quitte à aller à
mettre de côté ou en tout cas à moins
prendre en compte les électeurs qui ont
sont tentés par emmanuel macron moi je
crois que c'est il faut pas réfléchir
segment électoral et ça je ne parle pas
pour les candidats je parle pour ce que
je pense très sincèrement il faut parler
aux français du monde dans lequel ils
vivent effectivement il ya plusieurs
visibilité parce que quand vous habitez
paris centre de paris vous n'avez pas
tout à fait le même spectacle qu'on
vivait au coeur de carpentras voilà et
c'est toute la problématique des
républicains c'est que nous sommes le
dernier parti le seul parti sur
l'échiquier républicain l'échiquier
pardon un peu politique à proposer une
solution qui soit une solution de
concorde et réconciliation à des france
qui ne se parlent plus aujourd'hui sa g
des républicains s'est pas que vous avez
une candidate qui a des mots qui
pourrait être employée par eric ciotti
qu'il ya un programme qui est celui
d'eric ciotti avec un visage qui est
celui du centre droit est ce que du coup
ça fait pas une candidate un sens non
parce que par exemple sur le sur la
politique sociale tout ce qu'elle
déroule sur la hausse des salaires sur
la défiscalisation des pensions
alimentaires sur le cumul emploi
retraite enfin je veux dire on renoue si
vous voulez avec une tradition qui est
une tradition gaulliste social donc elle
a en réalité grand prix ça de plus tôt
de xavier bertrand oui je dirais effet
xavier bertrand lui qui dit et ça vous
allez non confirmées ou pas qui il a dit
valérie pécresse il faut retrouver la
valérie du réseau
on a perdu la valeur est énorme c'est à
dire que lors de la lors de jolis dit la
même chose lors du grand meeting du
dimanche
je crois qu'il ya eu si vous voulez des
instructions un peu contradictoire il
faut que tu sois comme s'ils faisaient
présidentielle foutu fendre l'armure il
faut que tu renverses la table il faut
que ce soit le grand tournant et à la
fin autant sur le fond j'étais
pleinement d'accord autant sur la forme
on sait très bien que c'est pas la base
l'exercice qu'elle préfère et on sent
qu'il n'était pas à l'aise c'est un
meeting raquet sur la femme pour vous
perfectible ces jeunes la cour des
comptes
non non pas rater parce que autant au
début d'abord puis les problèmes de son
et c'est autant quand elle je vais vous
dire la vraie valérie pécresse on l'a
retrouvée pour moi lorsqu'elle a
commencé à parler d'elle-même et tous
les ans de prison et tout de suite ça
c'est vu trois quarts d'heure on a connu
les français la connaissent vous la
voyez sur bfm tv vous l'a vu sur
d'autres émissions où elle lorsqu'elle
parle directement c'est celle ci celle
du congrès celle qui est libre en fait
parce que je crois que dans une élection
présidentielle effectivement elle a fait
l'union mais le message que j'ai compris
que les libertés c'est dire maintenant
c'est fait l'union il faut que tu te des
tâches aussi les gens qui te conseille
qui t'entourent pts et eric ciotti mais
peut-être aussi xavier bertrand il faut
qu'elle soit elle même on vient on vient
de parler de la forme avant de parler du
fond juste dire la question vous disiez
tout à l'heure que dimanche valérie
pécresse et tout le monde était là du du
centre à la droite de la droite le
spectre était très large tout le monde
sauf une personne on a quand même
remarqué l'absence de nicolas sarkozy le
fait qu'ils s'engagent pas aux côtés de
valérie pécresse que c'est un problème
qu'est ce que ça veut dire non c'est pas
un problème ça n'a aucune à aucune
espèce d'incidence ça n'a aucune
incidence je vais vous dire pourquoi
d'abord parce que
c'est si vous voulez c'est évidemment le
fait d'avoir des soutiens du dernier
président de droite en exercice c'est
important symboliquement mais on est ici
au début de la campagne présidentielle
quand vous avez et je dirais
votre arme fatale vous la sortez pas au
début vous la sortez à la fin et on aura
sans doute besoin de nicolas sarkozy
dans un entre-deux tours qui pourrait
être compliqué pour
moi enfin si j'étais candidat je
demanderai plutôt une école je sortirai
pas un début et je sentirai plus tôt à
la fin mais vous êtes sûr de son aliment
vous attendez pourquoi parce que
aujourd'hui les français ils veulent pas
la réélection de jacques chirac la
réélection du scar dessin ou la
réélection de nicolas sarkozy ils ont
déjà tranché sur cette question
aujourd'hui ils ont une femme qui
connaissent pour certains fameux bien
notamment en ile de france et pour doute
assez méconnu et ils ont besoin de
comprendre et qu'elle ne se cache pas
derrière des mousquetaires etc pour la
découvrir en tant que tel c'est elle
parce que ils se disent qu'ils cette
femme qui peut être la première femme à
présider à me dire qu'aujourd'hui
nicolas sarkozy pour vous c'est plus un
atout pour un candidat non j'ai pas dit
ça puisque je vous ai dit que
j'ai dit c'est le jour du riz
aujourd'hui la première place elle doit
être occupé par valérie pécresse et
c'est elle que les gens doivent
connaître les soutiens qui sont
intéressants mais écouter ce que disent
et xavier bertrand puisque vous les
citer il faut qu'elle apparaisse elle
même parce que c'est sur c'est sur sa
personnalité que nous gagnerons c'est
parce que les français comprend des
médias eric ciotti il est trop présent
dans cette campagne pas du tout je
trouve qu eric je trouve qu'il connaît
les autres muscles
non je ne sont pas du tout 2 fera pas du
tout c'est normal qu'il en est dans le
congrès il a fait 40 % des voix nous
avons un électorat qui est partagé en
deux qu'on le veuille ou non vous en
avez une partie qui est plutôt
attiré par les sirènes emmanuel macron
et valérie pécresse lui plaît beaucoup
et une partie qui pourrait être attiré
par exe pour eric ce qui lui plaît
beaucoup eh bien vous ne pourrez pas
s'ils voulaient séparer de toute façon
vous n'avez plus votre alchimie est donc
le congrès il s'est fait ainsi et je
crois qu'il joue son rôle il fait un
travail un bhl il va sur le terrain
comme les autres d'ailleurs et je crois
que c'est cette image d'union qui ont
leur dévouement et d'insister mais je
veux bien
sur les explications que vous nous
donnez sur nicolas sarkozy mais alors du
coup pourquoi valérie pécresse va
chercher noir balladur faisait poser la
question avait effectivement
je crois si vous voulez que alors est
d'abord permettez-moi edouard balladur
est une personnalité importante mais cet
ancien premier ministre c'est pas un
ancien président de la république
edouard balladur c'est la crédibilité
c'est la compétence
nicolas nicolas sarkozy je dirais c'est
plus un message de fond et puis regardez
vous vous nous dites déjà rendez vous
contre vous utilisez des mots forts
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas trop à droite
nicolas sarkozy ce à un centriste si
vous voulez donc si vous avez nicolas
sarkozy et en plus vous avez un discours
très agréable qu'est ce que j'aurais
entendu je veux dire à madame hidalgo
aurait déjà demandé est-ce qu'on soit
suspendu de cette élection
présidentielle une dernière précision
concernant nicolas sarkozy vous n'avez
pas peur qu'il annonce son ralliement à
aimer le macron à quelques jours de la
présidentielle comme comme comme
certains de ses proches pensent à eric
woerth par exemple je n'ai pas peur
d'eux je pense qu'il doit être libre
aujourd'hui il n'est plus dans notre
famille politique il a quitté la
politique active donc il est libre après
il vit mais il sait très bien sa
responsabilité à l'égard d'une famille
politique il sait très bien que s'il
allait soutient emmanuel macron ça veut
dire que demain vous revenez à la
troisième république vous avez un grand
parti qu'on appelait d'ailleurs les
opportunistes à l'époque et au tour que
des extrêmes et ça va être la
désespérance démocratique cirque pour
l'élection d'un homme qui au passage
ailleurs un bilan assez contrasté on
pourrait en parler vous allez fourni en
français un seul choix vous aurez un
choix de raison ou alors vous aurez des
gens qui ont des parts des propositions
approximatives ou des propositions très
radicales et qui peuvent pas gagner que
je vais vous dire c'est avec ça on n'a
pas une révolution dans les dix ans à
venir ce sera
moi je les redoute pas mais je trouve ça
déplorable parce que vous perdiez une
élection parce que l'autre est meilleur
mais là vous avez déjà lu stx les
gaulois samba les gaulois les les
pirates rabier du pirate pas les pieds
attachés ils sont coulés par les gaulois
il ya un épisode célèbre où les pirates
à force de se faire couler voir astérix
et obélix et 10 arrivent les goulots
arrive et donc ils coulent leur propre
bateau est bien ça vous voyez c'est
désespérant
ce
que je veux dire c'est que si vous si au
bout de cinq ans vous avez chemin de
damas où passer cinq ans à critiquer le
président de la république et comme par
hasard deux mois avant vous apercevez
qu'en fait il est très bon mais pourquoi
vous n'avez pas vu avant vous auriez
libéré en plus la présidence de la
commission des finances at on bien
l'état l'opposition et puis pour le pour
les citoyens et zimmer nous prend pour
des imbéciles
et en plus je vous dis il ya quelques
mois on avait d'un côté guillaume
pelletier et de leucate eric woerth qui
s'est expliqué dans la presse ce qui
faisait qu'on disait les républicains
sont divisés à la fin vous avez un qui
parle quasiment le qui partent chez
makro mais si c'était pour arriver à ce
résultat il fallait partir en 2000 7 on
aurait vécu un championnat beaucoup plus
apaisé sur des discussions internes un
moment donné il faut respecter les
électeurs voilà est-ce qu'on peut
revenir rapidement changé vous nous dire
sur la troisième république les
opportunistes au centre les extrêmes
extrême gauche extrême droite est ce que
ça c'est pas ce qui nous pend au nez
après la présidentielle une
recomposition du paysage politique
français autour de ce que vous venez de
décrire je crois que si emmanuel macron
est réélu parce que sa stratégie cynique
en fait des piétements du champ
politique eustache qui arrive à la
droite ce qui arrive à la gauche
aujourd'hui arrive à la droite demain
s'il arrive à ce résultat là vous aurez
la vème république
factuellement mais sur le fond ce sera
la troisième est en partie la quatrième
avec un aspect effectivement deux grands
partis d'opportuniste parce que quand
vous allez de barbara pompili à eric
woerth excusez moi ça s'appelle plutôt
united colours macro mais quand vous
dites c'est désespérant et ce serait ça
serait le signe avant-coureur ou le
début de quelque chose qui pourrait mal
se terminer vous avez parlé de
révolution dans les dix ans qui viennent
est-ce qu'on peut pas avoir des soucis
beaucoup plus rapidement si notamment à
eric zemmour ou une marine le pen ou un
jean luc mélenchon n'accède pas à la
présidentielle faute de parrainages est
ce que vous n'avez pas peur qu'on soit
dans un scud et moi de réemployer stage
mais dans un contexte où les gens se
disent qu'est ce que c'est que cette
campagne où il n'y a pas de débat il se
passe rien et en plus des gens qui pèse
ne peuvent pas y aller et que ça ça
provoque
du wild eyes and go qui est à 2 5% qui
peut se présenter un eric zemmour on
peut penser et c'est très glissant sans
parrainage est terrible les 500
parrainages public en réalité est-ce que
qu'est ce que les républicains peut
faire valider ses parrainages est ce que
vous allez appeler par exemple à un
certain nombre de vos élus alors moi
j'ai parrainé des ddd grand air des
bâtiments ce nom de françois bayrou du
président de la république qui permet
aux gens de se présenter ça vous avez la
lie du président de la république qui
dit voilà je vais créer une banque des
parrainages et puis je vais autoriser
que ça c'est une mauvaise idée comme sur
le trône est comme sur le scan sous le
second empire on va pouvoir autoriser
comme dans les républiques africaines un
tournant selon le président la
république vous autorise à concourir
comme vous pouvez pas gagner bon voilà
on vous donne la possibilité de venir
bras en marche la dette on croit si vous
voulez que toutes les solutions aux
problèmes sont forcément démocratique le
risque de cette négligence de l'électeur
de ce mépris pour les électeurs de cette
de ce2 ce message nous envoyer qu'on
peut changer d'étiquette au lendemain
abandonné trahir le fait que vous êtes
dans une société politique où vous ne
vous ne savez plus le jean qui rit les
gens qui sont loyaux mais les gens qui
sont des traîtres tout ça peut conduire
effectivement les français à se dire bah
maintenant on va tous les balayer
regardez ce qui arrive le convoi de la
liberté où les gilet jaune ce sont des
soubresauts mais c'est le masque profond
en réalité d'une rupture du consensus 58
il faut retourner au référendum c'est
pour ça que valérie pécresse a raison il
faut retourner au peuple souverain
ouais on avait dit qu'on parlait un peu
de fond vous allez trouver que
l'ensemble des propositions de valérie
pécresse était était clair dimanche est
ce que tout ça ça fait une vision
structurée de la france où est-ce qu'on
n'est pas plutôt dans un catalogue alors
je trouve qu'elle a justement peut pas
essayer de faire un inventaire à la
prévert effectivement il y avait
beaucoup de sujets parce qu'elle a
quatre priorités mais c'est toujours la
difficulté du bon équilibre en tout cas
elle a des propositions et ce sont des
propositions innovantes et disruptive
effectivement là où je peux vous
concéder un point c'est que quand vous
avez beaucoup de propositions innovantes
disruptive bien on retiendrait que celui
qui a une proposition démagogique et
inapplicable
voilà donc ça veut dire qu'il faut
qu'elle se concentre peut-être plus sur
quelque chose qu'on retienne aujourd'hui
à rien qu'ils sont vus
ça veut dire que maintenant on a le
programme maintenant pour celui qui veut
écouter sur les femmes qui divorcent sur
le senior qui veut travailler après sa
retraite nous avons des propositions qui
sont des propositions extrêmement
précise et bien construite merci ni
envers merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
invité
[Musique]